[Music]
[Music]
i'm trevor phillips this is common
ground
in a world of conflict and division all
too many believe that if you're not with
us you must be against us
but does every problem have to be solved
by the loudest voices or the biggest
armies
britain says that by 2050 we must by law
reduce our net greenhouse gas emissions
to zero
tonight we're asking if we can still
afford to reach net zero or whether we
can afford not to
for some cities choking with smog
violent weather events and disappearing
coastlines spelled the end of humanity
for others no coal no oil means poverty
and misery for the world's poor
the prime minister talks up electric
vehicles in the promise of clean nuclear
power
his chancellor cuts the cost of petrol
as the cost of living crisis risks
becoming an emergency
the choice is start is it now time to
put our commitments to net zero on hold
in the next 60 minutes two passionate
believers come head to head in the
search for common ground
[Music]
with me tonight mark littlewood director
general of the institute of economic
affairs
and sepi golzari monroe acting director
of the energy and climate intelligence
unit
start with you sepi
why should we stick
with the net zero
well trevor net zero honestly really
means energy security it means an
unhampered foreign policy it means
national
security and it means cheap and
affordable energy bills for the people
up and down this country we've seen
recently that gas prices are five times
uh what they were a year ago this is a
volatile international market
manipulated by hostile states and
actually net zero offers us the
opportunity to have energy security much
more energy sovereignty and to lower
people's bills at the same time while
protecting the planet okay mark um
should we stick with net zero or abandon
it
i'd abandon it not because i'm against a
policy of decarbonisation i'm not a
climate denier and i'm very much in
favor of the things that seppi have set
um
energy security lower bills all of the
rest of it
uh but i would abandon it because i
think it is an overly costly and overly
specific target i think the idea that we
can predict that in 28 years time we
need to be at exactly net zero you know
cutting by 90 not enough a hundred
percent it's got to be at sort of one
minute past midnight on the first
january 2050
is an extremely attractive policy for
politicians who want to grab headlines
but not a sensible policy either for
energy or for the environment
mark um you could be
in here talking to us about all sorts of
things
why is this one important to you
personally um it's important to me
personally because i i think it's
probably the most important long-term
policy debate of our times uh obviously
what's unfolding in the ukraine at the
moment important what's unfolding around
number 10's potential breach of covid
rules important but if you wanted to
pick one topic which is going to
really dominate political debate always
be in the top three for the next 20 or
30 years it's this it's this one it is
important it is significant and it's
important to get to the bottom of it and
understand the trade-offs involved in it
that's why i'm here okay seppie um and
why does it matter to you personally
you've been an academic you can you
could you're clever about all sorts of
things why this one
because i love this country
this country actually by meeting net
zero is not only protecting its natural
heritage its natural landscape the
woodlands the coastlines the wildlife
it's actually getting ahead of the
economic reality the global economic
reality that net zero is happening i
care about this because not only do i
want my children to actually benefit
from the natural environment that i've
benefited from but also to really have a
strong
prosperous world-beating economy to look
forward to so they can build their lives
on a really strong foundation
all right well look we start with some
agreement that this actually is the most
important thing
for the next oh 30 years certainly as
long as i'm about around and about okay
let me buy that for the moment let's
start with your
um your case sepi
honestly today we've got home energy
bills
uh rising we don't know quite how much
but it'll be
tens of percentages i mean we could be
paying three thousand pounds a year
typically for our uh energy
we will
uh have to pay a lot of money to deliver
net zero uh some people reckon
above a trillion pounds between now and
the middle of the century up to 1.4
trillion i think the office of budget
responsibility says
um we can't afford it can we i mean in
our real life
uh it's a great aim
but surely it's not realistic
let's take your points one by one you're
talking about the price hike in energy
bills which is affecting people up and
down this country everyone wants to have
the ability to heat their home and to
put food on the table and not to have to
make the difficult choices between those
two incredibly important things but
unfortunately our reliance on fossil
fuels it's the gas price
that's spiked that's causing
these bills to go up up up so it's
really not at all connected to our
ambition for net zero that the energy
bills of people up and down this country
are going up by 73 percent in two days
time
and by the end of the year they're more
than a double you're adding another cost
to people who are already having to pay
that to the country actually the
renewables that are online now are
actually shielding uh households from
this gas price to some extent the
renewables that we've been able to roll
out in the last decade have actually are
actually providing much cheaper
electricity into the grid they've
displaced this expensive gas
and so they're actually helping shield
us but if we'd actually rolled out more
if people hadn't been delaying and
putting a de facto ban on onshore wind
and delaying our progress then we could
have been saving even more money so we
know that the 2013 dictat from david
cameron to cut the green
you know can say the work
cut the green crab has actually cost
households 2.5 billion pounds the the
policy to cut
energy efficiency programs not only
decimated this growing industry
people lost hundreds of jobs but has
actually cost
households
200 pounds extra on their bills
well that's very interesting to hear but
doesn't yet have any public policy
implications if sepi believes she can
provide very cheap energy by setting up
a whole load of wind farms or by some
new hydrogen technology or by a break
few breakthrough in nuclear fusion or
some other weird wonderful scientific
technique that i've not yet conceived of
good luck to her i will not stand in her
way let a thousand flowers bloom and i'm
very open-minded on how we get our
energy supply in future and if there are
you know weird and wonderful and magical
ways of doing that that cut bills count
me in but what we're here to discuss
trevor is what's the public policy
framework for that are we going to
punish certain forms of energy and
reward others and the carbon net zero
agenda is to punish in my view with some
justification
energy generation that isn't carbon
neutral that has as an economist would
say an externality that if you're you
know digging for coal
that might be great that you can keep
people warm but the problem is you're
causing damage to other people so i've
got no qualms at all about lots of new
wonderful technologies coming on stream
my question is what's the public policy
framework to bring that about and are we
picking winners and favoring one
particular supply over another and
what's the cost of it and what
trade-offs are involved and i'm very
worried about those can i respond to
that directly actually because uh
you know you talk about magical thinking
i mean this is happening today we've got
we've got
electricity generation
from our wind turbines providing
electricity at a quarter of the cost of
gas so it's not magical matter what's
today it's happening today but i'm not
sure you really want to see it because
if you wanted to see you'd see
that actually we've got this incredible
resource all around these islands that
can bring down bills can provide
national security mean that we don't
have to rely on a russian game playing
for our household economics to actually
work out so
let me let me put this to you though um
even if we didn't get all of that
um you know
that we are going to
uh have to go through some kind of
transition we won't be going from you
know lots of gas and lots of fossil
fuels to all wind they're going to have
to be a transition and in that
transition
i think even your own work suggests that
there's going to have to be a reliance
on fossil fuels probably gas the
cleanest we can get but it will still be
gas maybe even new forms kind of coal so
you're not actually against
uh the burning of fossil fuels at all
bear in mind this is net zero not zero
zero exactly but you know you have to
look at these things in in um you know
in in a different a number of different
ways so for example we have got these
frameworks that by 2035 actually most
electricity generation uh will be
renewables but you know there is of
course you said the point about net zero
that you know we're not saying that all
fossil fuels have to go tomorrow this is
about a transition it's about transition
that we need to happen people across
this country understand they want to
protect their natural environment they
want to protect it for future
generations and they want to protect our
economy and make sure that we are
getting ahead
you know whether whether mark believes
it or not this is an economic reality so
whether you believe in the science or
not that's beside the point this is an
economic reality 136 countries around
the world have got a net zero target 19
out of members of the g20 have got a net
zero target this
is the new reality this is what we need
to work with if we want a prosperous
economy yeah but what i thought we were
here to debate was whether this new
reality is a good idea or a bad idea uh
i agree with you you've got hundreds of
countries signing up to this i'm
skeptical it will happen i'm not
skeptical about the science by the way
the science that seems to be settled is
that greenhouse gases warm the
environment and clearly at some point
that has a destructive effect i think
there's there's more of an open debate
on how destructive that effect would be
i'm by no means a denier about it i what
i want to get to the bottom of
is can we be so specific in predicting
the future that we know
here today sitting in this studio that
the contribution the united kingdom
needs to make to decarbonization is to
get to exactly net zero at exactly one
minute past midnight on the 1st of
january 2050. are we really able to
predict it with that specificity and
targets like we must stop the global
temperature rising by more than 1.5
degrees as if 1.49 is absolutely fine
and 1.51 is a disaster so i'm not
skeptical about the science i'm not
skeptical about new forms of energy i am
skeptical about grand central planning
targets brought in by governments i
don't think that's the best way to
achieve the ends that you and i actually
so so in summary basically you're waving
a flag but you actually know your heart
for heart we'll never get there
that's completely mistaken so if you
want investors to invest
in the industries of the future in the
economy of the future to create jobs up
and down this country to make sure that
the people of this country have a
prosperous economy you need to give
market signals you need to show them
that this is actually where the world is
going but frankly they don't even
necessarily need that specific one point
you can they can open their eyes and
they have done and they see it happening
all across the world so what i'm saying
is actually if mark mark says we're here
to debate whether it's a good idea or a
bad idea but then he says he doesn't
dispute the science
that doesn't that doesn't absolutely i'm
not sure how you've got to get to
exactly carbon net zero in the united
kingdom on the 1st of january 2015. the
science tells you greenhouse gases
let me tell you what the science says
the science says that to have a good
chance of getting of keeping
temperatures well below two degrees into
keeping them to 1.5 degrees which is the
internationally agreed ambition
the global economy needs to reach net
zero by mid-century now that's slightly
different so with developed countries we
can meet it somewhat sooner some some
countries will meet it somewhat later
it's not
as prescriptive as marcus trying to set
out seppie we've just got a few seconds
before we go to the break but um i just
want to ask you about one other thing to
make this happen you've got you've got
to have public support um
to what extent do you think the
environmental movement
is helping i mean
at one level
if you read what some
people who are on your side this
argument um do they come across as
basically hair shirted zealots they
block roads they stop us going to work
and talk um
if this is going to go your way
you're going to have to do persuade
people in a rather different way aren't
you
first of all i'd say there's huge
support up and down the country for
tackling climate change people are
incredibly concerned about it it's
something we we agree on people want it
to be tackled in fact you know it was in
the conservative party manifesto on the
front page that they would put in in law
net zero by 20 in 2019 by 2050. so it's
there people voted for it and actually
people by ratio of two to one want the
government just to get on and deliver
its manifesto commitment
all right well look i think we've got we
got somewhere um there's no climate
deniers in this studio uh
there will be a transition
uh but the question is
is it realistic we're gonna talk more
about that in a moment stay with us i'll
be testing the ground further
but it already looks like uh
who knows we might get to something like
common ground at the end of this
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they have breached the road there is a
lot of gas being fired all around us
[Music]
it is an absolute carnival kind of
atmosphere out here for prime minister
modern
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
the roads have been inundated the only
way out is to get people by boat
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today it's
absolutely deserted
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
[Music]
[Applause]
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is common ground i'm joined once
again by mark littlewood director
general of the institute of economic
affairs and sepi goldzari monroe acting
director of the energy and climate
intelligence unit and we're talking
about whether the cost of living crisis
and concerns about our energy security
mean that we should put our legal
commitments to a net zero economy on
hold um
mark uh
this isn't just a british issue is it i
mean
britain hasn't decided to do this on its
own there's um i think now 150 nations
source they're about committed uh to net
zero
but
the way you talk about it at the first
sign of difficulty it looked like we
bail out what happened to british
leadership
well no i think you can show leadership
on these things i mean thank god it
isn't only a british issue there'd be
absolutely no point in us getting to
carbon let's zero if the rest of the
world showed no interest whatsoever i
mean that would be an exercise in
preposterous self-flagellation for
absolutely no gain at all so it's only
worth doing this in a global context
greenhouse emissions global warming
climate change are global problems and i
have no problem with britain leading on
that and pointing it out and you need to
get an agreement of countries across the
board of course you do i have no
argument with any of that that is common
ground between us my question is is this
remotely the right and sensible way of
bringing about decarbonisation and i
think it isn't think so
well i might just think so we can't be
the only ones who are right
well i'm not sure everybody else does
think so i think this is likely to be a
rather contentious uh issue about not
just the rights and wrongs of going for
it uh but the means by which we try and
bring decarbonisation about and it's on
that latter point that i'm i think it's
preposterous the way we're tackling this
i mean i would essentially have one club
in my golf set i would have a carbon tax
and i would say right activities that
emit carbon and cause damage to the
environment will have to price those and
you'll face attacks
activities some of the um not magical
new thinking but weird and wonderful
sciences that sepi was talking about
that don't have the same carbon
emissions they will not be taxed that
then brings about a market uh price if
you're trying to generate energy in a
very high carbon way coal for example
it'll end up being more expensive and if
you're trying to if you've found a way
of generating energy in a lower carbon
way or a zero carbon way it will be
cheaper and the market can then do its
magic people will want the sepi carbon
free energy rather than the little wood
carbon intensive energy because mine
will be taxed more and the price will be
passed out and that then gives you the
flexibility trevor so it's not a perfect
analogy but it's a bit like using
interest rates to combat inflation
uh now that's been observed in the
breach recently but the idea is there's
a tool and you dial up the price of
money if inflation is a problem and i
would see a carbon tax working something
like that here we go sepi the invisible
hand why not
i mean let's be honest people have been
talking about a carbon tax for
20 30 years now and it just simply
hasn't delivered so by all means keep
working on it keep trying to to make it
happen
but in the meantime let's crack on with
what we know works which is uh giving
investment certainty uh for for
companies to invest you know we've got
i suppose let me tell you what i'm most
worried about here with with with mark's
approach
is that
by just delaying and dithering and
flip-flopping
that we miss out on the economic
opportunities industrial opportunities
offered to us
now if we get ahead if we actually build
the industries that we can then you know
sell to the world that we can expose
that we can bring jobs to this country
and bring benefit to this country
yeah but that's
i'm not standing in the way of anybody
creating jobs or investing or building
new ways of finding energy
you say we should do this get on and do
it i i by no means stand in the way i
look forward to it let a thousand
flowers bloom
what i'm focused on is the public policy
around it i don't think there's
differing to say that we should try and
find a way of correctly pricing carbon
that's the only sensible policy the
problem is on the other end seppi says
she's looking for certainty you get
uncertainty in this market on a
practically daily basis we discover in
the spring statement that solar panels
are now going to be subsidized
let's take let's stick with your case
for a moment you know
a few moments ago you were um attacking
sepi's case for essentially being a
little bit uh pie and sky
with you know uncertain technologies and
so on now you're offering the economics
if i remember rightly in my youth was
once described as voodoo economics here
is the one here is a one club and which
will magically make everything happen
you don't really believe that do you it
won't magically make everything happen
because that's beyond the wit of
politicians and bureaucrats and
campaigners however when entertainment
you're bypassing that you're saying
let's make it let's get let's put the
price mechanism in and that's what will
force everybody to do the right thing it
won't force people but it will
incentivize people in the right way
that's what it will do
it's not magic it will require brilliant
scientists entrepreneurs
inventors hard workers engineers and all
of the rest of it to bring this about it
can't be done just by the environment
secretary standing up and wishing it to
be so the number of people involved in
this and investors and all of the rest
there's a million moving parts my
suggestion of the public policy
framework is to try and set the price
right if they focused on that rather
than announcements that we're going to
specifically i don't know ban the diesel
car by 2030 or we're specifically going
to subsidise now solar panels in your
house or have a particular five grand
kickback on a heat pump lots of tiny
fiddly interventions that cause
confusion and uncertainty on a daily
basis i don't know how you judge where
the market's likely to go next far
better i say to stop the divering and
the the tiny little interventions set a
price
um
certainly at uk level you need to then
have agreements with other countries on
how we would uh treat their imports or
whether you'd have mutual recognition
and then let the brilliant people who
understand this industry inside out cepi
will understand it far better than i do
i'm not here as an investor or an expert
on the energy industry i'm here as an
economist that's the best way of getting
that to decarbonization and having the
humility that we don't yet know at this
stage exactly what we want to achieve
supposing the science starts to indicate
that carbon emissions are worse than we
initially thought well we might need to
put the price of carbon up supposing
actually the stocks unfold it's not
quite as bad as we thought you could
allow the price of carbon to go down so
it's a very simple public policy
framework that gives you flexibility
with updated and unfolding science
what's not to love
as i said by all means crack on keep
going keep working on it make it work uh
but in the time that it's going to take
uh mark
and and and others to actually develop
that framework
then agree with all
uh of the parties that he's he's just
talked about i mean you know goodness
knows how far down the line will be but
at the moment what we've got is by
setting a phase-out date for the sale of
new uh new petrol and diesel cars for
example we're now seeing investment in
this country gigafactories being
developed in breathing life into our old
industrial heartlands bringing jobs 6
200 jobs in sunderland another thought a
few thousand in in the port of blyth
these are coming in order to keep our
uh automotive industry alive and kicking
and selling
abroad mark um before we uh in this
section um
i've got to ask you this uh
you run a very successful distinguished
think tank the institute for economic
affairs um
can you reassure me and indeed our
viewers but you don't you're not making
this argument which is essentially no
regulations no pressures on private
companies because they're funding you i
mean you i think you got you get some
money from at least one big oil company
is that right gladly accept money from
anyone who's willing to give it to us
but i can assure you that my argument is
entirely sincere you trevor or eusepi
might disagree with it but people give
the ia money because they agree with our
approach not the other way around and if
anybody doubts that they can try and
write me a check to say something that
isn't free market and they will see
their check return to them by return of
post right okay well that's the first
time in a long time i've seen anybody in
television say i'll give you your money
back but anyway just to say that if
you're interested in the net zero debate
do make sure you watch sky's daily
climate show which is on at half past
eight monday to friday here on sky news
coming up we've heard what the guests
think and why about their own positions
next i want to begin the search for
common ground in earnest
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back i'm joined once again by
mark littlewood director general of the
institute of economic affairs and sepi
golzari munro acting director of the
energy and climate intelligence unit and
we're talking about whether the cost of
living crisis and concerns about our
energy security mean that we should put
our commitments to a net zero economy on
hold and we've heard quite a lot about
what our guests think and why now
here's a big challenge uh and it's one
that we might struggle to meet can we
find
if not
complete common ground at least some
common understanding between uh our two
so
let me start in a way by
um
challenging both of you or let me start
with you
sepi could there be ways in which we
could
get to net zero less painfully for
example
does it really have to be 20 50 given
that we've had covet given that we've
got
uh a war in
europe and so on there are
pretty good reasons for saying
maybe it's time to push this back a bit
that's only if you're assuming that it's
going to cost you more but as we're
showing at the moment as we we're shown
sorry we're being shown through our
energy bills that actually going for net
zero will cut the bills that households
are paying they're going to be paying
from to
from two days time their energy bills
will have gone up 73
in one year alone and will more than
double by october so we know that and we
know that that's driven by our
dependence on fossil fuels we know that
our sanctions regime our foreign policy
has been hampered by our dependence
on fossil fuels and so the reality is is
that this is actually a benefit to us
you know the question you pose assumes
that it's it's a disbenefit actually
it's of benefit to us to act now and not
only that then even if you take into
account uh you know of course some some
costs uh the reality is that um office
for budget responsibility actually said
that delaying action uh by 10 years will
double
the investment you have to make so it's
a no-brainer but that's true but in the
same obr report i mean they they paint
three different scenarios don't they
early action uh don't do anything uh
take action later and yes it it would
cost more but the thing is
even if you took action as you would
like now
uh it's still going to cost you the best
at the thick end of one and a half i
need to truly no i need to sorry i just
need to come in on that they actually
said that there's a the cost and then
there's the benefit and once you weigh
those against one another over the
course of 30 years it comes down
significantly to the point where
actually the annual cost will be the
same amount as we paid for rod repairs
in 2020 21. the question i'm really
asking is do we absolutely need to nail
ourselves to a cross labeled 2050.
the science says that the world globally
needs to meet net zero by around
mid-century and that developed economies
economies that have benefited from
polluting this world by causing this
crisis
do have a responsibility to go faster
what i'm saying is we have a
responsibility to go faster but my
goodness don't we benefit from going
faster to strengthen our economy to make
sure that we get ahead in the 21st
century industries that then we
can be
strong
in the world in our economy and actually
benefit ourselves
i mean my problem here and sorry trevor
this won't be getting us to common
ground is i don't buy that this is win
win win win win win win all of the way
from here to
2050. i'd like us to accept some common
ground that there are trade-offs here i
accept they are there are trade-offs and
they're difficult and they're
contestable uh i do not believe it will
be free to get to carbon net zero by
2050. if it would be and that's the way
the world's moving anyway we don't need
any government interventions that's just
where we'll end up because wonderful new
technologies will come online we'll
choose to do so anybody everybody wants
it it will be cheaper you're telling us
no public policy needed then that's just
entrepreneurialism at work i suspect
that there are trade-offs and it will be
expensive to get there and the cost of
energy will increase not decrease and
that there are meaningful considerations
there i mean we know for sake of
argument that 20 000 people a year
roughly in britain die of hypothermia
if energy goes up in price and cost and
we've got this heat or eat decision
you'd expect that number to rise those
are real people here and now and so i
don't i don't buy that it's all win win
win win i'm not wishing it away by
saying we don't need to do anything
about carbon emissions at all i'm not
saying that i'm saying there are a
number of balancing
problems challenges some opportunities
and costs and we've got to get that
balance right that there isn't a policy
which is everybody wins all of the time
between now and 2050. well one one
dimension of the trade-off that you're
talking about mark is
the is time the when which i've just
been asking sheppy about
another dimension is where geography uh
you say you know
carbon tax
we will make the market the market will
essentially take us in a virtuous
direction
well of course the problem is that's
never going to be symmetrical it's
symmetrical and uniform everywhere and
while we find our way gradually towards
the right balance um
the marshall islands have sunk below the
sea
uh your isn't your
uh proposal or your way of approaching
this rather a selfish one no because i
think that there's uh you need to
consider not just mitigation that's what
we've been talking about let's get to
carbon net zero let's remove as much co2
as we can as fast as we can from the
atmosphere you do need to consider
adaptation as well i think that's
another area of public policy supposing
you knew it wasn't something as dramatic
as that trevor but we knew for sake of
argument no don't suppose because that
is what it is well that could
in that case what's the adaptation but
everybody's moving out of the martial
arts yeah well you compensate the losers
at some point don't you i can't
compensate people for the fact that
their house is 24 under what underwater
let's suppose that we knew that the only
impact of climate change will be a
million people will be displaced across
the world let's just take that i'm not
saying that is the case let's just
assume that was the scale of the problem
we were going to
be embracing because their houses would
be underwater let's assume that's the
scale of the problem
would we be better to exclusively pursue
a policy that would mitigate that and
ensure that their houses were never
under the water or would be better to
say those people need to be fully
compensated moved to much nicer houses
somewhere else would actually be the
better way of dealing with the problem
if we know that flooding is going to
increase in the united kingdom again
sake of arguments hypothetical i'm not
necessarily predicting that are we
better to say here and now we need to do
everything we can to stop that and lower
the risk or is it also worth looking at
whether we could for example improve our
flood defenses such that flooding is
more common but doesn't cause as much
damage
sorry there are a few points there that
we we need to unpack so again mark uh we
need to we need to debunk this myth he
keeps talking about paying more for our
energy bills and people are paying more
for their energy bills because of our
reliance on fossil fuels expensive
expensive gas we haven't stopped the
north sea drilling the north sea is a
very mature basin we've pumped we're
pumping as much as we can essentially
out of it there's an obligation to get
maximum value out of the north sea which
is what they've been doing so the
reality is is we we he keeps talking
about expensive energy in net zero and
trying to equate the two it's unrelated
expensive energy and fossil fuels are
what are related so we need to just
get that back on the table because mark
keeps trying to bring that back but the
facts on the ground tell us otherwise
the people whose energy bills are
skyrocketing in two days time will be
able to tell mark otherwise now in terms
of adaptation
the reality is is the more the the the
more the world warms the more we will of
course have to adapt there's some
adaptation that we have to do that's
already baked in because of the over one
degree of warming that we're seeing now
the more that we see the more money
we'll have to spend on adapting and it's
just what i mean we have to address i
know he said the one million point just
for argument's sake we're talking about
a
whole lot more people than that being
displaced from their homes mass
migration
you know there's there's there's
actually
coastal cities in the uk that are
already um you know really losing out
fairborne property prices have plummeted
because it's already being impacted by
rising seasons so we're trying to unpack
this i mean we could do more in the
north sea and i think the government's
likely to take a more liberal attitude
there we've decided not to pursue a
shale industry in the united kingdom
for what i consider my limited
understanding of the sciences for
slightly hysterical reasons the us has
pursued that uh has gone for shale
energy bills in the u.s not as big as an
issue as they are here in part because
they now have developed a fantastic
shale gas industry we're leaving our
stuff in the ground we've been highly
hesitant on nuclear now i have some
issues on whether it should be
subsidised i don't really want the state
involved but i think we could have been
a lot quicker on bringing small modular
nuclear reactors to market so in my view
the price is going up in part i mean
there's the whole ukraine issue and
there are global economic issues it's
not in the hands of the uk government
but we haven't done a great deal to
mitigate that domestically we've decided
now shale gas we're not going to go for
it the north sea we could have done more
on we've been very slow on nuclear when
i said at the outset that a thousand
flowers bloom i mean it and i think
there's a good number of flowers that
we've got which we're not allowing to
bloom and i would like to see them come
to market that would help cut the costs
even if they aren't carbon free energy
they might be lower carbon dioxide
let me come back to come back on a few
of those points fracking you cannot
equate the uk with the us
we've had experts if you don't believe
me you can look at the experts that
probably wouldn't be able to i've done
research on this for the last four or
five years they tell us that the geology
in the uk is just simply not
uh
equatable with the us the us has
different geological structures it's got
different geography and uh frankly it's
much more commercially viable
to frack for shale gas in the us but the
reason actually gas is
is cheaper in the u.s is because the u.s
is not able physically able to export as
much gas as it would like because it
doesn't have the infrastructure and so
it's actually in a an artificially
closed market which is so which is why
it's gas is cheaper we are in an
international market
we have nowhere near the supplies to
compete with the likes of russia saudi
arabia
they are the people that set the price
their manipulation or geopolitical game
playing sets the price for british for
households
in britain
i'm not predicting i'm not enough of a
geological expert to know i'm not
predicting that a shale revolution here
would be identical to that in the usa
what i am saying is that there are
commercial outfits who are interested in
exploring this who are being hampered in
their efforts by government dictat and
it seems to me full i mean nuclear is
another example we've been so slow on
nuclear it's absolutely unbelievable
there's a different issue so
unfortunately there are new energy
scopes
let you ever get awarded no no no this
is your argument this is yours
i mean look but there's one thing which
clearly does divide you one is the
extent to which uh the state government
can make a difference that's clear
um
the other which i want to just explore
very briefly uh the minute few minutes
we've got left here in this part is
uh one about
time really it still seems to me that
you are divided
uh by
a sense of urgency really uh in the
sense that you're saying sepi that
whatever we've got to do something
whatever we can do right now right now
right now whereas you're saying mark
that you think
that
human ingenuity uh
uh
time the market and so on will has g
will give us the opportunity to solve
this before it becomes
too problematic
um is that is that actually a thing that
divided both of our positions
that's my job i'm sitting here with two
with two cartoon characters
so listen the point actually no i i
would disagree actually with that
outline of my position i'm afraid um
sorry about that um
no no i'm not saying right now right now
right now you know i'm talking about
government as governments or wants to do
is to set a
policy framework
and allow the market to deliver and
essentially it's not right now right now
right now we're talking about you know
uh no no no no no no nine years to phase
out uh the the the
if you've got one to achieve what you
want to do but you need to you need to
you need to start now it doesn't mean
you need to deliver everything today you
need to start now but not you need to
start now for environmental reasons but
you need to start now for economic
reasons to make sure our economy is i
must give my chance to to correct my
complete
complete no i'm not
i suppose it was a fair summary in part
i'm not just saying we can ignore all of
this and everything will come right
because i'm sure that there's a great
bunch of scientists out there who'll
crack it all i'm not i'm not as i'm not
as laisse faire as that i do think
incentives uh work in the system but
trevor you were asking about the
trade-off between today and tomorrow and
there's two elements of this that i i
think are important
one is what economists would call the
discount rate um we do you know we're
not sure where we'll be in 100 years
time uh and we value things in the here
and now and i think that's reasonable
and rational the second thing is most
likely we will be better equipped to
deal with problems in the future than we
are today or than we were in the past
that's the most likely thing don't want
to rely on that 100 percent but it seems
to me that human history suggests that
that's something in broad terms we can
rely
all right coming up we've heard from our
guests
and their views
we'll ask them next whether they see any
prospect for common ground and
i'll give my view
do stay with us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
they say they can't go back to myanmar
yet if they do they fear they'll be
killed
[Applause]
[Music]
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
if there is a bigger explosion this area
would be in the danger zone
[Music]
these traffic jams snake for hours up
and down this hillside it means pressure
day you can't access those and neat
[Music]
you can see the depth of water if you
have a look in front of us there are
people wading through it
[Music]
i think experiencing the two million
person march in hong kong
that was a moment
i don't like the chinese government it's
true
it was real people power in action
police have been firing tear gas and
rubber bullets
see fires all around us here and just
one of them is the size of around 31 000
football pitches
shabon robins sky news bangkok
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back i'm joined once again by
mark littlewood director general of the
institute of economic affairs and seppi
golzari munro acting director of the
energy and climate intelligence unit
we're talking about whether the cost of
living crisis and concerns about our
energy security mean that we should put
our commitments to a net zero economy on
hold well we're coming to the end now so
i'm going to give each of you uh one
minute to tell me what you feel you
might have learned from our conversation
and if anything that you've heard has
actually changed your mind about the
other's view you don't have to but if
you do
sepi why don't you start
well i think i've learned that mark's
approach wouldn't actually address the
cost of living crisis that people are
facing because of skyrocketing at gas
prices the dependence on fossil fuels
and i think i've also learned that
actually we will still be subject to the
whims of uh hostile nations such as
russia
because we're hampered in our foreign
policy we can't put sanctions on the the
russian
energy sector because the west is so
dependent uh on on their fossil fuels so
i think i've learned that actually we
won't really make a difference to
households today and it won't help uh
get us the investment that we need in
order to strengthen our economy
and anything you said
changed your mind yeah i mean i think i
think i very much agree with mark um
about the nuclear issue
unfortunately the the past few decades
successive governments have seen that
you know
to be dithering and delaying but that's
partly because nuclear is so expensive
mark got some common ground here i
haven't solved the problem of energy
security uh i haven't tried to and i
haven't sold the cost-living crisis i
don't think either sticking to or
abandoning carbon net zero will have any
impact on the cost of living today that
requires other measures
i think there is some common ground here
actually and
i'll doff my cat to sepia in a way she's
quite optimistic usually when i'm
involved in this debate i'm involved
with people over the other side of the
table who are saying that if we don't do
exactly what they're saying exactly now
armageddon is a certainty sort of by
thursday next week not in seppi's case i
think she sees that um it's going to be
invention and entrepreneurialism and
innovation that solves these problems
and there is common ground between you
and i on that
point
there does need to be a public policy
framework there's agreement between you
and i on that point however i'm more
optimistic than you i think we can get a
simpler better publicly policy framework
than the highly sub-optimal
interventionist fiddly one we have at
the moment so some common ground
all right well look this is this has
been very fascinating um i mean
obviously i kind of expected that the
two of you would disagree about the
extent to which
policy could make a a huge difference
and you're more optimistic about that
you're less optimistic about that uh i
think it is clear that
whether either of you likes it or not
you do have a slight leaning
uh in different ways about what matters
and a sense of urgency and except you
know you're not crazy you've got to do
things today and you're not crazy leave
it leave it till forever but you do have
different leadings well what does strike
me is that i think there is some common
ground here you both clearly believe
that science has a role to play
and you both actually do believe that
policy
can actually make a difference um so
here here i am i've got i've got a
proposal
you've got a think tank you've got a
think tank
why not bring them together i think the
optimistic the possible pro-science
think-tank that could help solve this
problem for humanity
i think we've got an answer here thank
you both very much indeed
that is
it from us for this week next week we'll
be joined by two more passionate
advocates in the search for common
ground
join us then
[Music]
you